often and the reason why I
mention it so often is because
I want these names to ingrain
themselves into people's minds.
The names of our scholars, the
names of the companions, the
names of the various authors,
the names of the different
scholars and their specialties.
am constantly repeating these
names in hopes that these names
would become commonplace to the
listener. Just as
unfortunately, we have been
bombarded by popular society
with the various names of
celebrities and
non-mentionables. it it is
important that we strive and go
out of our way actually to
learn who our forefathers are
because a person who has no
history has no identity. and so
this book, again, I reiterate,
is authored by an imam. , the
great Mufaser, the great Faki,
of Islam. , Shem Suddin, Ibn
Kaim, Al Jozia, Rahim Ahu
Ta'ala. And Ibn ul Kaim wrote
this book Zad al Mahad and it
is one of the most
groundbreaking and influential
books in this particular genre
or in this particular vein of
subject. Now, when I say
subject, you know, Zad Al Maad
kind of broke the mold. It's
not a book that has a
particular subject per se. It's
a book it is it has many many
subjects but all of these
subjects revolve around a
revolve around a common a
common point and that is the
prophet Muhammad so it is a
book of it's a book of
explaining the of the prophet
it's a book of hadith it's a
book of medicine he has an
entire volume which is the
medicine of the prophet and he
alphabetized that that volume
so any illness or any issue you
look under the letter regarding
that particular just a
dictionary and you find Ibn
mentions whatever was narrated
from the prophet with regards
to that particular issue.
Likewise, it's a book of the
biography of the prophet It's a
book of history. The history of
the prophet and his companions.
It's a book
thee the things that are
particular to him. That really
get us to know who he was and
give us details about his his
his actual physical attributes
and so forth. These are called
things that he would do, things
that he would constantly do
things that are particular to
him, the names of his wives,
the names, the names of his and
the names of his guards, the
names of his ambassadors, the
names of his disciples and and
memorizing and reciting and and
transmitting the Quran
etcetera. So it's a very very
broad book. It's a very book
but since it's writing this
book has been a reference for
everyone who writes in this
topic and on this subject after
Ibn Rahim. Even Ibn Hajr Rahima
Allah in his astounding work
Bukhari.
this he mentions a lot and he
references this book a lot
because his book is an
explanation of Sahih Al Bukhari
and it's almost you can't
do that without Ibn ul Kaim and
his book Zad Al Maad coming
into play at some point there.
We had stopped or we had taken
our break at the point where we
reached the chapter in the book
of fasting. How the prophet
would fast and so on and so
forth. We will get into those
details and we will discuss
inshallah tonight. We will
begin with the with virtue of
fasting and second of all, we
will get into the history of
fasting and then after that, we
will get into the rulings
fasting. What is fasting? And
it's pillars along with that
which invalidates a person's
fast or which nullifies a
person's fast. Which you may be
surprised is actually very
simple. A lot more simpler than
you may have previously
thought. The prophet
commanded
fasting and he
encouraged fasting at any time.
a person can fast anytime of
the month, anytime of the week,
anytime of the year but there
are certain times when a person
should fast along with another
day, meaning that you should
not specifically choose this
particular day to fast only in.
And what we're speaking about
is fasting Friday alone. or
Saturday alone Now, if a person
has an obligatory fast or if
they fast the fasting of Dawud
Alaihi Salam, which the prophet
allowed and encouraged. He was
asked about the best of
fasting, he said,
Dawood,
Alaihi Salam, that Dawud Alihi
Salam, the best of fasting is
the fasting of Dawud, the
prophet Dawud Alaihi Salam. He
would fast one day and he would
break his fast the next. So,
every other day, he would fast.
Now, if a person fast in this
way, One week, their fast is
going to land on a Friday
alone, right? And the next
week, it's going to land on a
Saturday alone. That's how it's
going to work. if a person is
fasting in this way, that's
fine. Or if a person has some
day that, let's say you're
working all week and you have
one day off, let's say it's a
Saturday or a Friday and you
have some fast that you need to
do and you fast that day in
order to because it's your day
off and it's easier for you to
fast or what have you and it's
fine to fast. on that day
alone. However, it is not
permissible to choose Friday to
fast or to choose Saturday to
fast out of reverence for these
days specifically, right? So,
Friday is a revered day with
the Muslims but we do not
choose it to fast alone on that
day. So, the prophet
specifically said, in a
narration, narration these
narrations on the authority of
and and others in a Sunan that
Not fast Friday alone, without
fasting a day before it, or a
day after it. Likewise, fasting
Saturday, do not fast Saturday
alone without fasting a day
before, to a day after it. And
that is to to separate
ourselves from other religions
that you know, other religions
that you know, honor these
particular days of the week
with fasting. out otherwise a
person is encouraged to fast
anytime of the week or the
month and there is a time when
fasting is obligatory obviously
with conditions and that is the
month of Ramadan. Month of
Ramadan is the ninth month. In
the Islamic lunar calendar. It
is either 29 or thirty days.
And
it is a time when a person is
to fast based on the actions of
the general mass of their
community. Which is another
topic that we will touch on
that is very important
inshallah. With regards to
fasting. fasting the month
of Ramadan that is. But before
we get into that we'll speak
about fasting in general.
Fasting in general is not only
it has many virtues. very
good book to read on this would
be the book of the virtues of
fasting from the book of
fasting in Bukhari, book of
fasting in Sahih Muslim. These
are very prominent books, very
good books to read with regards
to the virtues of fasting. But
one of the most important
things that fasting does for
the person is that it aids a
person in controlling his or
her sexual drive. This is very
important because the prophet
was asked as is in a about the
thing that lands most people in
the hell fire and he said he
said, the mouth and thee and
the private parts. These these
two organs and what a person
does with them, they are the
tongue and the private parts,
they are the two things that
mostly people into the hell
fire. So, one of the things
that fasting does is it helps
you to control your sexual
desire. There is a narration in
Muslim in which the prophet
said
wedge.
He said, whoever of you has the
ability to marry, then he
should do so And if you are
unable, especially he said from
the youth,
Yashaba Al Muslim Ian, he
directed this to the youth, but
it's to anybody, but especially
those who are young have a much
stronger sexual drive obviously
than those who are older. ,
for the most part, again,
society and the environment
will play a huge part in that.
What do I mean by that? Well,
if we live in a hyper
sexualized society we do
now and it's not just here in
America. So, it's all over the
world because of the internet
and because of the exportation
of ideas and godlessness we see
that we live in a very hyper
sexualized time. Everywhere you
look, everything. The way
people dress, the way people
speak, their jokes, the videos,
innocent things, even things
children's TV shows, even
cartoon characters are drawn in
a way that articulate
articulate sexuality and this
is something that's extremely
dangerous and deadly in our
time and it's one of the
greatest greatest
traps of a Shaitan. Because a
Shaitan uses two main things to
envelop society in to destroy
religion in society. Two main
things. He uses oppression from
tyrants and those in the those
in charge of people. And he
uses as well.
people's desires chiefly,
sexual drive because it drives
to the heart of human nature
This these two things are the
ways two of the chief ways that
a Shaitan destroys societies
with oppression and desire. And
so,
If a person lives in such a
society or such a time, you may
find a person who's fifty, 60,
70, 80 years old and they are
they are sexually deviant,
right? Sexually deviant with
sexual orientations that are
outrageous, not just
heterosexual tendencies. And
why is that? It's because of
the environment, the
environment makes this
sixty-seven fifty, 80-year-old
man or woman constantly think
about this thing as if it is,
if as if they are teenagers or
as if they are in their
twenties. They take pride in it
and it's you know, people on
their shoulder with regards to
this and this is very
troubling, very worrisome.
Usually, a person's sexual
drive is is to deplete after
they reach a certain age and
they reach a certain level of
wisdom and they calm down,
right? And the enthusiasm of
youth leaves their their body.
you know, These things
become marginal, a marginal
part of their life. Doesn't
become a chief part of their
life. However, when society is
hyper sexualized as we see, it
is around us. a person may
become very old and and still
be involved in these kinds of
things. So, the prophet said,
whoever has the ability to
marry, then he should. and
if a person is unable to marry,
then, he is to fast. Because
fasting is a type of armor and
it helps a person too. its
hold and control better his or
her sexual drive. Now, fasting
here in this narration has been
explained by the scholars in
two ways. Number one, fasting
obviously legislative fasting.
Fasting, not eating or drinking
anything from sun from the
break of dawn until sunset. But
also, fasting can be used in a
linguistic sense, which means
that a person not only fasts in
the legislative sense, but they
also fast in the linguistic
sense, which means that they,
that they, less the amount of
food that they take. They don't
eat till they're full all of
the time. because when a
person is hungry, they are less
prone and their sex drive is
weakened. When a person is
completely satisfied and they
are full, right? From eating
and drinking. They're not
hungry. They're not thirsty.
The sex drive starts too.
climb. And sometimes with
certain people, it can get you
know, grossly out control and
so it's not just that a person
fast you know Monday and
Thursday or fast but it also
means that if you have an
inability to redirect your sex
drive to the point that it is
out of control or it is then a
person is to lessen their food
intake. They're not to eat a
full meal, make themselves
completely full. They should
eat moderately This is also a
type of fasting and also one of
the implications of the
narration. Because if I if I
eat a huge meal before I start
fasting and then I fast for 10
hours and then I eat a huge
meal after. I'm kind of
shooting myself in the toe. But
if a person whether they're
fasting or not they are always
eating moderately. This will
help a person too. get these
get these impulses under
control. Now, about the history
of the legislation of fasting.
It's important for us to know
the history of the legislation
of fasting. Ibn
ul Kaim, Rahim, Almi, Thalath.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
this was in the second year
after Hijra and he said Ramadan
Quran.
this these verses here, these
two verses in they articulate
the obligation of fasting and
they specify the month of
Ramadan specifically. That that
is the month that we are to
fast. Now, this fasting of the
month of Ramadan had three
stages to it. The first stage,
is that a person was commanded
to fast but they had choice to
either fast or feed a poor
person for every day that they
miss. So, just a person
who's you know, terminally ill
or a person who is they they
have a Kafara for fasting. So,
they they cannot fast because
of old age or because of
long-term sickness or illness
or whatever it is. So, they
give the Kafara, right? They
give the expiation which is to
feed a poor person for every
day of the month of Ra bond
that they miss. This was
something that anyone could do
at the very beginning. So, when
fasting was first obligated, a
person could do either or. They
could either choose to fast or
they could, choose to feed a
poor person on behalf of that
day. Whether they were young or
old, sick, or healthy. This was
the first stage. The second
stage was that fasting became
obligatory upon ever body who
was able bodied to do so and
was not traveling or ill and
this stage had a very specific
condition to it. And that is if
a person let's say a person
fasted all day and came in and
they fell asleep or eating.
They were not able to eat again
until the next day. So, if a
person
A person is fasting, comes in,
they go home and you know, they
were sitting, waiting for the
food to be made or something
that and they fell asleep
without eating anything and
they woke up, challahs, they
can't eat until the next day at
Mehrib. That was the second,
the second stage. The third
stage was fasting as we know it
today. It doesn't have that
condition on it anymore. Now, a
person may say, well, why these
stages? Right? First of all,
when people were first
obligated to fast the entirety
of the month of Ramadan, it
took an entire society to
adjust to this. It wasn't just
one person. So, when we look at
it from this aspect, we see why
a person would not implement
these stages now. What what do
I mean by that? Well, what I
mean is that let's say a person
comes into Islam new, right? Or
just to fast. Well, then why
wouldn't they start with having
the choice of either fasting or
feeding a poor person, right?
Because that's how fasting was
first obligated, correct? Yes,
but that was for a society in
as a whole. That was not for
individuals, right? Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala was
obligating something upon an
entire society And so, this
stage of intensifying, fasting,
and until it is the way that we
have it today. These stages
were critical in order for the
entirety of society to be able
to transition smoothly.
However, when we have one
singular person who enters into
Islam or one person who begins
to fast, we don't have that
issue. This one person can just
start fasting, right? So, this
is why a Nestle took place
which is that a ruling would
would be sent down and then
added to or taken from this
ruling to adjust for the time
and place in order to make
legislation easier or in order
for to make legislation at
first very difficult and then
go to something which is
easier. So that it can train
and build discipline in the
people. It goes both ways. It
can start out very hard and
then become easier or it can
start out very easy and become
gradually more difficult So, we
have the first is that as a
society, they were first
commanded to fast the month of
Ramadan but they could choose
between giving the Kafara or
fasting but fasting was always
considered to be superior. He
said, Subhanahu wa ta'ala and
if you are to fast, that is
better. So, you had the choice
but fasting was encouraged and
was better than giving the
Kafara. Second of all, we had
an intensive intensification,
right? So, first, we had, it
was very easy. Then, it became
actually more difficult because
if you fell asleep before
eating, you had to fast the
next day as well without eating
anything. You couldn't have or
anything. So, that made it very
difficult, right? So, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
transitioned from easy to
extreme or difficult and then
brought it back to a middle
place which was it's obligated
but as long as the sun is down
you you can eat or drink
anything that you and this
was to adjust the society to be
able to follow this
legislation. Again, we're
speaking about the First
Society of Islam. When the
children of the companions were
born into this, they were born
into a world where the month of
Ramadan was fasted, right? So
We didn't need this kind of
legislation. When people
entered into Islam, they
entered into a community of
people that were all fasting
and had this discipline. And so
they taught this discipline to
others. But when the first
people were commanded to fast,
the month of Ramadan, the
prophet and his companions,
they had to build up this
discipline. They had to build
up this momentum. And this is
why these stages were the they
are. So, these are the three
stages in the legislation of
fasting the month of Ramadan.
After which, the third stage
was to fast from the break of
dawn until the sun set. No
matter how long or short the
day is, for those who are able
bodied, right and those who are
not traveling. So, there are
three instances when a person
breaks his fast. When a person
doesn't fast the month of
Ramadan. Three chief instances.
Number one, is that a person is
traveling? Number two, is that
a person is ill. Number three,
that a person is in battle. If
a person is in battle, they
don't fast. okay? Even if it's
Ramadan. we have in the
conquest of Mecca which was in
the seventh or eighth year,
difference of opinion amongst
the historians. After Hijrah,
we see that the prophet
commanded the companions as
they were at the gates of of
Mecca and this was in Bramadan
to break their fast. So, they
were commanded to break their
fast. Why were they commanded
to break their fast? They were
commanded break their fast
because they were entering in
into a situation where battle
was expected. Where fighting
was expected.
Now, a perk, we we said three
main things, three chief
things. Number one was
traveling. Number two was
illness. Number three, was
battle. Now,
There are
other exceptions but
they fall under under the
generalities of these three,
okay? What do I mean by that? A
woman who is breastfeeding or a
woman who is pregnant or a very
old man or very old woman.
These people, they fall under
the generality of those who
have the ruling of being ill.
Whether it's short term or long
term, right? So, a person who's
very old for instance. This
person is able to fast but
fasting is very difficult for
this person. Where may be
impossible for this person to
fast. But even if they can fast
but with great difficulty, they
fall under the generality of
the ruling of one who is either
ill, short-time illness, or
long-term illness. Being that
it's for the sake of old age,
it's usually going to be that
of long-term illness which
means that they will pay the
expiation by feeding a poor
person for everyday that they
miss of Ramadan. Likewise,
woman who is breastfeeding or a
woman who is pregnant. A woman
who is pregnant for nine
months, they have time to make
up their fast, correct? they
have time to make up their
fast. If she is only going to
and this is a question that is
often asked. If she is going to
be able to make up her fast
before the next year of Ramadan
comes around, then, she just
makes up her fast. That's it.
But if she is breastfeeding in
that case, she will pay the
kafara, right? So, this
question comes up a lot and
that is, a woman may be
pregnant and then when she has
her baby, she's going to
breastfeed her baby. So, now,
she doesn't have to fast
because she's breastfeeding and
then after that, she gets
pregnant again and then after
that, she's breastfeeding again
and then after that, so she
might have six, seven, eight
years, I had a woman actually
asked me one time. She had
eight years of Ramadan worth of
fasting
you know,
eight, eight months
of fasting to make up is she to
make it up? Of course not.
You're going to be fasting all
the entire year and the most
strenuous the most strenuous
expiation or punishment in the
Quran with regards to fasting
is how many months? How many
months is it? Two months,
right? As for accidentally
killing somebody. Right? Or
that's for of the heart, right?
It's two months fasting So, we
see that the greatest amount
that has ever been placed on a
person with regards to fasting
is how many months? Two months.
So, if a woman misses two
Ramadan, she has two months or
worth of fasting. This is now
transitioned from being fasting
the month of Ramadan to incur
the favor of Allah into a kind
of stressful punishment, right?
Likewise, the punishment for
intercourse during the Ramadan
is what? Two months fasting,
right? So, this question comes
up a lot and that is that
should the woman make up her
fast? The answer is no. if
she misses more than one
Ramadan because of the type of
issue that we just mentioned,
then, she merely pays the
Kafara the expiation, feeding a
single a single poor poor
person. for every day that she
misses of Ramadan, right? For
every day that she misses of
Ramadan, that's it. She doesn't
have to make up two and 3 and 4
years worth of fasting. this
is excessive and this is the of
Ibn and others is mentions in
his now
This is because she falls under
the generality of somebody who
is, she has the same ruling as
someone who is ill with a
long-term illness, right?
Because if a person has a
long-term illness that prevents
them from fasting for two
years, three years, doesn't
think that they're going to
ever be better or the
projection of their healing
process is going to be far into
the future, then, this person
doesn't fast. This person pays
the expiation. Likewise, is the
issue of a person who has
become very old or a person who
is unable to fast because she
is either breastfeeding or she
is.
So, this is a question that a
lot of people ask and that is
the answer to that question. It
comes up every year. I'm sure
it'll come up this year.
Anyways, but it's good to know
the for those of us who are
married, those of us who have
that the question comes up that
a woman misses Ramadan or
missus Days of Ramadan due to
pregnancy or breastfeeding.
What should she do? The answer
is she should make up these A's
unless another Ramadan comes
around Then she will only pay
the expiation for those days.
Right?
Now, what are the upon whom is
fasting obligatory? Upon whom
is fasting obligatory? This is
a question. that's very
important. For us to know who,
a person, who who are the
people who are obligated to
fast. Though the scholars tell
us, from collecting the verses
and the narrations of the
prophet and the patterns of
Islam and Islamic law and
students. We see that we have
conditions for a person to
meet, criteria in order for
fasting to be considered
obligatory upon this person.
The first is that a person is
that a person is that a person
is of age, of pubescent age.
We're speaking about
obligatory. Okay, binding
Wajib. When we speak about it
is Wajib, it is obligatory.
Nothing is obligatory upon a
person until they are of
pubescent age. Correct? They
have to reach the age of
puberty before anything is
obligatory upon them. But does
this mean that we don't have
our children fast before they
reach the age of puberty? What
is the age of puber let's speak
about this first. absolute
latest.
The absolute latest or a person
who is a late bloomer as they
would. To reach the age of
puberty is 15 years old. Anyone
above the year the age of 15
years old has reached the age
of puberty. All of the
legislations of Islam are
binding upon this person.
Notice how I said fifteen and
not What what comes to mind
usually when we think of
adulthood? Eighteen, right? Why
why does eighteen come to mind?
Huh? Tell me. I can't hear you,
man.
18 comes to mind because that's
the society we grew up in,
right? Legal age, legal age of
adulthood is eighteen, right?
But when we look at the
legislation of Islam and that
is the but it's it's it's not
really based on anything
substantial. The correct
opinion is fifteen. And the
reason for that is that we see
of an youth would come and
stand whenever they companions
would go out for battle. and
they would come and ask to go
to battle But the prophet would
walk and choose. Jews who was
allowed and who was too young.
From the youth. Of of the
companion. So
stood in this line. And he was
14. He as he said. And the
prophet sent him back. but the
next year, he stood in the same
line and he was 15 and the
prophet took him with him to
battle. So, what does this
mean? This means that at the
age of fifteen, this kind of
battle becomes obligatory upon,
upon a person or a person
becomes eligible for battle at
this age. From this narration,
the scholars have taken the
have taken that. The latest age
of puberty is 15 years old. As
the latest age. The earliest
age could be nine years old, 10
years old, based on what the
body does. Puberty is when the
mind reaches a certain a
certain level of understanding
in which it becomes able to
comprehend right and wrong and
the consequences of right and
wrong. This is the essence of
puberty, okay? Now, when the
mind, the brain, reaches that
level it starts to secrete
certain chemicals into the body
and the body starts to show
signs of that maturity. Okay?
and the signs of that maturity
come in the form of come in the
form of a girl having her her
monthly cycle. a boy reaching
the age of which means that
they would have a a wet dream
and and experience in in in
their sleep. Or that a person
starts to get armpit hair and
have pubic hair. That's why
it's called pubic hair because
it is part of puberty. And so
these are indicators that the
brain and the mind has reached
a level of maturity. In which
this can now be held
accountable for right and wrong
and that they understand not
just that this is right and
wrong but they understand the
consequences of right and
wrong. So, puberty is an
indicator of that. We will
continue with this topic next
week inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]
thank you very much for your
presence